E aí
[Música]
E como você acolhe as diversas formas de
existir
essa pergunta parece muito fácil de
responder quando a gente
tenta responder de forma automática Mas
eu vou pedir para você esperar um pouco
e refletir junto comigo se tivesse
formas de existir são essas meu nome é
Luciana Eu sou artista sou mulher negra
sou mãe de um garoto autista
nascida dentro do Capão Redondo mas
criada no interior de São Paulo Trabalho
com educação inclusiva há quase 10 anos
e tô aqui para fazer a gente refletir
sobre essa diversidade de existir a
minha perspectiva sobre
deficiência diversidade bem antes eu
tenho um filho com deficiência e deu
saber que eu era uma pessoa com
deficiência
e ela começou a eu fui criada dentro das
escolas de samba dentro dos terreiros
levada pelo meu pai Zé Inácio pela minha
mãe dona Ana e ali eu vi acontecer
dentro das aulas das escolas de samba
diversidade de forma plena inclusão de
forma plena era ali mesmo que eu
encontrava pessoas com diversas
deficiências
envolvidas no processo da inclusão
envolvidas no processo de colocar a
escola de samba na avenida
bom e era muito engraçado porque
você pode me perguntar Luciana aquele
lugar era acessível para essas pessoas e
eu vou dizer para vocês não
Luciana aquelas pessoas com deficiência
que trabalhavam nas escolas de samba se
sentiu incluídas e eu afirmo para vocês
que sim
porque a inclusão se dá por meio da
relação e eu vou provar o que eu tô
falando eu sou professora da rede
pública e na escola a gente ouve muito
eu preciso me
especializar para lidar com meu filho ou
para lidar com meu aluno eu preciso
demais é horas complementares saber mais
sobre a deficiência para lidar com meu
aluno e a gente acaba esquecendo do
principal ponto que é a inclusão se dá
através da relação Inclusive a inclusão
do professor com o aluno a relação ela é
fundamental
e estar no mundo mais inclusivo e
acessível e é muito comum a gente
generalizar essa ideia né de inclusão é
precisamos de horas complementares
precisamos de especialização precisamos
de legendar nossos conteúdos Legends seu
Story Descreva as suas imagens e por aí
vai
é mas será que de fato inclusão e
acessibilidade é só isso será que de
fato a gente precisa pensar em
acessibilidade
apenas no sentido técnico é comum dentro
da rede a gente tratar inclusão como
método mas eu volto a afirmar a inclusão
se dá através da relação melhor a
inclusão se dá através do afeto
a gente só incluí que a gente ama e eu
vou falar que eu descobri isso quando eu
era maior de idade conheci um amigo
através da internet e a gente marcou de
sair né viramos a noite
conversamos foi muito divertido o
passeio tudo vamos um show nos
divertimos ao final do show meu amigo
olha para mim me diz assim
e olha preciso te falar uma coisa eu sou
surdo oralizado e eu faço leitura labial
hoje por conta do lugar que a gente tava
eu não consegui fazer mas eu adorei eu
amei passear com você foi muito legal
foi muito divertido conversar com você e
foi muito bacana é dessa troca e eu tô
contando isso no final do nosso doce em
conta porque se Depois disso você não
quiser mais ser minha amiga tudo bem mas
já valeu nosso encontro
e ali o meu amigo me ensinou coisas
muito muito bacanas e complexas primeiro
deficiência faz parte da identidade
segundo a gente primeiro se relacionou
para depois pensarmos em métodos de
inclusão mais para frente eu aprendi
libras para poder me comunicar com ele e
o inclui na minha vida e a gente
consegue a gente amigo até hoje a gente
irmãos mesmo é é
muito legal pensar como a inclusão se dá
nesse processo como a diversidade forma
nesse processo e eu volto a afirmar a
inclusão faz parte da relação sem
relação não é possível incluir eu sou
uma pessoa autista desde pequena Acho
que desde que nascer Mais
especificamente uma mulher e lembra
autista e me dia entender como tal foi
aos 25 anos tardiamente desde que eu me
entendo com o mouse E desde que eu tenho
diagnóstico oficial de que os autista é
eu começo a perceber que ser uma mulher
negra e autista num país que
estruturalmente nos marginaliza não é
fácil e eu tô aqui para poder lembrar
que nós mulheres negras neurodivergentes
também estamos dentro desse processo de
estereótipo
racista Quando a nossa singularidade é
posta no jogo e é questionada não há o
que nos resta senão estereótipos sobre
nós mulheres negras autistas ou
neurodivergente talvez eu tenha me
esquecido de falar e de apresentar um
conceito que me abraçou muito nesse
processo de mim entender com uma mulher
autista que é o conceito da
neurodiversidade
mas o que é neurodiversidade é a
variabilidade
cognitiva adversidade da variabilidade
cognitiva e singularidade da mente
humana em resumo a diversidade É de fato
as várias formas de existir de vivenciar
a vida e o mundo mas então nós pessoas
com deficiência psicossocial somos o que
Já que todo mundo existe e vivenciar a
vida de uma forma singular e única
e nós pessoas com deficiência
psicossocial somos neurodivergentes a
neurodiversidade é para todos e a neuro
divergência para nós que temos uma forma
singular e específico Advance a
sociedade tem por grande fala que a
gente está numa realidade alternativa
sensorial e eu adoro esse termo porque a
gente vive na mesmo mundo no mesmo
planeta mais a gente percebe
sensorialmente de forma diversa isso é
muito legal de ser pensar e aí eu quero
fazer uma pergunta para vocês como então
nós vamos incluir pessoas com
deficiência psicossociais
e como que a gente pode de fato incluir
pessoas
neurodivergentes sendo que a gente nem
sabe o que essas pessoas têm
e volto a repetir a inclusão está nas
relações
todas não é só nas pessoas com
deficiência em todas as relações
e como descobrir isso eu queria um
Instagram chamado uma mãe preta out está
falando e nesse Instagram eu recebo
muitas mensagens de mulheres
neurodivergentes e negras que dizem eu
me sinto abraçada com seus textos a que
eu posso ser gente eu Finalmente
consegui um lugar em que eu consigo
entender quem eu sou
Ah e por que que eu tô falando tudo isso
porque falar sobre Deus diversidade
falar sobre medo de emergência da
perspectiva de uma mulher negra é algo
que quase não existe
nós mulheres negras estamos tendo que
dar conta de não construir
mais de tirar esse estereótipo que é
posto sobre nós nós não somos gentis nós
somos agressivas nós somos violentas e a
gente tem que dar conta dessas questões
no Instagram quando você vê uma mulher
negra neurodivergente contando a sua
história
e não é sobre mim que eu falo é sobre
todas nós é sobre as mulheres negras é
sobre as mulheres divergentes é sobre a
maternidade
de uma pessoa
neurodivergente é sobre a colher é sobre
as relações
bom então se você buscou esse vídeo para
tentar entender um método de lidar com
pessoas autistas o com pessoas com
deficiência
é o método que eu tenho é ame o afeto é
fundamental e principal para o processo
de inclusão E aí quando a gente acolhe e
a sensibiliza as relações agente
possibilita um novo mundo
acolher as relações é garantir que o
mundo seja mais inclusive mais acessível
e o que que é de fato inclusão é se
sentir parte de um todo se sentir parte
de um todo é se sentir pertencente ao
mundo que nos cabem
Então como podemos incluir
Aceite o dias bons aceita o dias ruins
aceite os dias contraditórios
possibilitar novas formas e acolher
novas formas de existir
a
entender que é na relação que a gente
consegue abraçar e acolher a inclusão só
acontece por meio do afeto e
[Música]